[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today jeffson
Indianapolis hi Jeff welcome to the
Ramsey Show hi Dave pleasure to talk
with you you too what's up my wife and I
are in our early 70s uh my son lives
about a mile from us he's in his early
40s he relocated back here to Indiana
from California about 11 years ago from
La where he was working in the music
business and uh he was going to take
over my insurance agent a few years uh
retired about 9 years ago so he did take
that over um he got into tax problems
when he was in California because he was
working for a music composer that
actually treated him as an employee but
paid him as an independent contractor so
he didn't know anything about paying
taxes got behind with the state and the
IRS end up owing them uh 30 or 40 Grand
I think we helped him work out a
structured repayment plan as a condition
to him coming back and getting into
insurance and that's been paid through
wage garnishments uh since then I
discussed with him before he came back
to need to stay on top of his taxes and
finances because he's never been good
with money during that period of time
many times I'd ask him if he was on this
and he' just blow up and wouldn't talk
to me about it three months ago he
called us and told us that he was in tax
debt to the IRS again and wanted his mom
and I to uh bail him out basically using
our share of his of of our estate when
we die uh we thought he'd probably owe
about 50 or
$60,000 turns out he hasn't filed any
state or federal tax returns for the
past four years nor has he paid any
estimated taxes for
2023 we're meeting with our accountant
next Thursday to go over all this to get
specific numbers but I'm guessing and
what I've seen it's going to be over
$200,000 and about half of that is just
interest and penalties you also hasn't
paid any 941 withholding or state
unemployment tax he has no business
being self-employed obviously so my
question is uh we have the assets to do
that but we would have to sell off
property and mutual funds we our in I
don't know if you need our income or
what exactly what's your net
worth net worth probably about 2.3
million and about 80 about uh roughly
half of that is in two piece is of real
estate our residents here in Indiana and
another home we own in Florida I'm sorry
Jee 80 including the including the real
estate uh the majority of our assets are
in IRA roths and 403bs from where my my
wife taught we've got about 14,000 what
does
heket what's his income at the insurance
company well he just resigned from that
position because after he took it over
he ran it into the ground and couldn't
make a go of it right now he's doing a
sales job and uh it seems to be going
pretty well but he's only been doing it
a couple of months he's making about
75,000 a year plus
bonuses is he is he
married he's not married he has an
eight-year-old granddaughter that we
absolutely love and uh spends a lot of
time with us uh he got he he uh was
going to get married but they did it
kind of reverse they got pregnant first
and then they they didn't get along so
they didn't get married so both of them
are here in town and both of them are
have jobs and or own businesses and they
they get along fine we we all get along
fine the insurance agency was yours and
you sold it or gave it to him it was I
actually worked for a captive company so
they actually owned it and when I left
they paid me a percentage of my renewals
and that's one one of the cornerstones
of my retirement now I so I didn't have
a say so so you had a book of business
but what did he come into he he didn't
take over your book did he he did pretty
much not all of it because they gave
some they split it was a big agency so
they split it up among other agents they
gave him about half of it okay je and he
ran your book into the ground okay ran
into the ground okay Jeff does he have
any other debt besides the tax debt that
you know of do you know what that number
looks like I don't think he owes he he
rents he doesn't own a home I don't
think he owes anything else he doesn't
have credit card debts a tax debts the
only one I'm that I'm aware
of I hear your discussed for his
behavior in your voice and I also hear I
also hear a dad that loves his son even
though he's been
stupid you hear very well
um so I guess there's two options one is
you bail him out which doesn't sound
real
appealing um if you don't bail him out
what happens he just has to work with
the IRS and for a lot of
years yeah actually grow up
yeah we got the thing is Dave this this
has happened so many times I can't count
them but you've been there to bail them
out every time yeah and we we had take
him out of high school because of his
behavior we had to sent him out to a a
survival camp in Idaho then we put him
in a private school in California and
all that required a second mortgage on
our house at the time uh we bailed him
out of a car loan that he didn't keep up
with that I co-signed for uh it's just
been one thing after another he just is
is I'm I'm okay with no being the answer
yeah I if it were me I wouldn't do it
here's here's here's what what I'm gonna
here's what I'm going to
suggest he got a he got a severance
package from the insurance company
that's going to pay out about 30 grand
over the next five years about 6,000 a
year I told him that we would help him
out if he would sign that over to me to
pay back what we're going to advance him
but I initially thought we could do the
whole amount I don't think you should do
any of that Jeff I really don't that's
the way I think that's the way I think I
think that he's grown and I think that
he makes a living it's he's not making
he's not poverty level there's nothing
wrong with him I think he just needs to
be a man and do man
things I totally agree with you and I
think you're a great
dad thank you there's one other one
other question to kind of take this out
a little further because I don't think
my son realizes how bad position he's in
if he pays this over the next 20 or 30
years he still may not have it paid off
when we die and that's all right we made
yeah but we have we have all of our all
of our assets and our our our real
estate is in trust and my daughter is
the trustee and the executive and we Cur
we currently put a clause in our will
that that allowed my son to take our
house here as part of his settlement of
the estate because he loves our home
but I'm concerned that if he doesn't
have this paid off I don't even know
that I want to leave leave that share of
the estate to him because I think the
IRS could put a lean on that they can
and after after he becomes the owner
they can yeah yeah and I want to make
sure that I mean ultimately it was for
him but it's ultimately also to go to
our granddaughter and I don't want to
eat up our share of that estate I think
you can I think these are two separate
questions do you help him today they are
yeah do you help him today Jaden I are
both saying sadly I probably
wouldn't I probably wouldn't that's the
way I'm thinking and then uh do I change
the de change the will uh in a few years
I might you can change it now you can
change it later can you put something in
there that says if the debts not paid
off the home goes elsewhere until the
debt is paid off you could leave an
interest for the granddaughter and
bypass it bypass the the kid they can't
seem to find his way yeah that's so sad
this is the Ramsey Show